[Music]
hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide the show
that celebrates the little guys and
let's start with a film that celebrates
cinema 7852 directed by alexander
philippe I once made a movie it was
intended to cause people to scream and
yell but now they're horrified to find
that some people took it seriously this
is a film all about the shower scene
from Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho it delves
deep into why this scene in particular
changed moviemaking and there are
fantastic interviews from actors
directors and film historian psycho you
felt could happen to you this was the
first movie that showed you can be naked
alone in a shower and someone who is
going to come in and just stab you I
guarantee you even if you're a hardcore
Alfred Hitchcock fan you will learn
something it's fascinating
check out 7852 in theaters this weekend
he has broken the Covenant of filmmaker
and audience
and the audience cannot wait to see more
[Music]
the other documentary I cannot recommend
highly enough is visage village or faces
places this is directed by Agnes Varda
and JR she is a legend in the French
new-wave the only female filmmaker
working at that time she's got an
incredible body of work he is a young
photographer who's known for his really
striking images which he pastes
large-scale on buildings these two join
up together for a trip around the North
French countryside where they meet
people in villages take their photo and
then put the images up for everyone to
see
dubaku no it's not that they it's a
lovely way to preserve the stories of
local villagers and junior and Agnes
have this fantastic relationship this
friendship where he's very tall she's
very small
he's young she's old he's at the
beginning of his career she's going
towards the end of it and they really
support each other they both love art
they both love the power of the image
and there's so much fun to watch
together so client I don't please don't
want anything this is a beautiful
documentary that'll just make you feel
so good check out faces places in
theaters this weekend
- Alicia products from miyabi - yeah it
is over here in your table and two films
I want to recommend to you quickly
before we go first is owner starring
rooney mara and ben mendelsohn two
actors at the top of their game here
they go head-to-head in a complex
dialogue-driven movie based on a play
about a girl who confronts the man that
sexually abused her as a child I've made
the biggest mistake of my entire life my
dad tried to find you they wanted to
hunt you down and kill you and the other
one the mayor it's stories directed by
Noah Baumbach it's all about a
dysfunctional family one of those really
great New York set in the dramas with
some comedic moments and interesting
characters a fantastic script and I have
to say I love Ben Stiller and Adam
Sandler as dramatic actors
[Music]
let's run through my recommendations all
of these films are fantastic you cannot
go wrong with 7852 the Hitchcock
documentary faces places with Agnes
Varda and junior Oona starring Rooney
Mara and Ben Mendelsohn and the mayor
wits stories which has been Stiller Adam
Sandler and many more in the cast and I
would love to know in the comments below
or on Twitter at Alicia Malone what are
your favorite movies about movies 7852
is now up there for me I'm Alicia Malone
I'll see you next time
[Music]